hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast beneficial microbes
sharing of the microbial informational
library presented by dr. John Thomas
professor emeritus West Virginia
University's School of Medicine we are
excited to bring you this educational
webcast
presented by libraries the leading
scientific social networking website
provider of virtual events and webinars
advancing scientific collaboration and
learning find Julie simmer off of lab
roots and I'll be your moderator for
today's event
before we begin I would like to remind
everyone that this event is interactive
we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time you want during the
presentation just click on the green Q&A
button and located in the lower left of
the presentation window and type your
question into the box that appears on
the screen we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for at the end
of the presentation also please notice
that you will be viewing the
presentation in the slide window to
enlarge the window just click on the
screen icon located in the lower right
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation please click on the
support button at the top right of the
presentation window or use the Q&A
button to let us know that you're having
a problem this is an educational webinar
and thus offers free continuing
education credits
after the webinar is over please click
on the CD button located in the bottom
left-hand corner of your webpage and
follow the process of obtaining your
credit please join me in welcoming dr.
John Thomas I will now turn the
presentation over to him
well hello everyone this is John Thomas
and it's a pleasure to talk to you today
about a topic which I've spent a long
time studying and evaluating and I want
to hopefully educate you to the whole
world of microbiology and how much it's
changing who we are and what we think
about ourselves I'm going to do this
with about five sections but right now I
just want to make sure you know that
I've also got some slides in here of me
I'm a skier and the National Ski
patroller and one of the points is that
although we're going to cover a lot of
information it's still a very important
point to enjoy what you do and love most
I've been a professor for a variety of
times at a variety of places but I want
you to realize that it's important that
I've been able to integrate three very
unique but integratable thoughts one as
I've been in medicine than in dentistry
and a clinical microbiologist which
gives me I think a unique perspective
about how what we're going to present
today is so influential and so important
the first part of my introduction will
really define how the world is changing
and who we are in it and what I want you
to realize is that there is a theory
which has evolved in the last 10 to 12
years which describes coevolution of
microbes and microbes with man and the
reality is I came up with the word I've
heard it before that we are involved in
a dual citizenship the reality is that
you and I are both parts of genomic
total and that there's a macro part and
there's a micro part and the new
concepts of dual citizenship really
address this generation as being a holo
biome and we're going to talk today a
lot about the micro is being beneficial
that are the micro part of the whole bio
but it is the macro together and there
are shared benefits and that's very
important there's a lot of talk about
this and the references here I think
will give you some clues but we need to
move on because I want you to recognize
that in my theme it's also been one that
was addressed by some very famous a very
famous speaker who came across the idea
that we must reassess our self-concept
who we are because now it's very
recognizable
microbes matter and the reality is that
when we together form a combination one
half of us essentially genetically is
going to be who we think we have been
but the second part will be who are the
microbes and what genetic strength they
provide it is a combination of both if
one looks at the greater part and for a
greater definition of this who we are
and the Hollow genome be made up of the
macro and the micro one can take a look
at this picture and sort of describe who
the components are but it's important to
recognize there are really three parts
then that make us who we are and that's
the person who is the homo sapiens it's
the microbiome but I will emphasize that
we have the microbiome or the fungal
part of our Hollow bio twirled and then
we have the environmental that is who we
are around us and those three things
together
will help us create an environment that
will move forward recognizing when I try
to put here and that is we are really
libraries of information in the holo bio
is a combination of libraries that are
human and libraries that are microbiota
addressed and the reality is again we
look at features distinguishing each the
human is about 10 to the 12 eukaryotic
cells there are at least 10 to the 14
prokaryotic cells and if one looks at
the gene pool that these represents the
library of information essentially
humans have about 23,000 genes and the
micro biota microbiota that is bacteria
and fungi have at least 10 million genes
and the reality is that if we examine
ourselves in a genetic sense the
informational potential of that
microbiome is quite remarkable and needs
to be further evaluated
which then drives another question and
we as you look at the bottom of the
slide
are essentially described by again the
microbiome of about 10,000 different
species of microbes to begin to focus on
how important our microbiota
is and the microbiota the bacteria and
fungi we need to begin to put in a
reasonable system and we've sort of gone
back to all of us looking at our
taxonomy and the bottom line is if you
look at phylum and class and perhaps
family we get a much better idea of how
we can measure changes that can be
reflective of disease and/or health and
there are really six of the phyla
that we have found that I will probably
describe many times throughout this
paper but the bacteria that are listed
in front of you as phyla represent truly
profile able microbes or organisms that
will give us some clue as to a change
from what should be or what has been
normal in our age from the development
of our microbiota at birth to the
development of the microbiota as we age
in this diagram we certainly see how
unique each of these six phyla
described in a zone throughout the human
body changes and is remarkably
characteristic of or associated with a
particular region and these regions are
blending and I remember as I was thought
we used to think of ourselves as is
anatomic locations in that week I want
you to change that a bit as we begin to
address ourselves and to recognize that
we flow from one site to another and the
microbes that inhabit that defined by
phyla are part of that so if we think
about ourselves and our microbiota and
the micro hobo beyond who are these
beneficial microbes and how how are they
able to do for us what is in essence a
shared responsibility and what you'll
see here is a definition that I've been
working with and it is that it provides
the beneficial microbes often associated
as probiotics but this be a little
broader in sense they provide a benefit
to hosts
a meaningful way west igniting there is
a shared benefit and I think that's
incredibly important not only does the
microbiome provide information to us we
provide information to the microbiome
the dual citizenship and the reality as
I've come up with intelligent symbiosis
would be a meaningful way and listed
here on this line are seven
characteristics that are a result in
that our interface between our dual
citizenship of microbes and human cells
there are quite a few as one can imagine
beneficial microbes and hello this deals
with medicine and dentistry and please
notice that I add the word dentistry
it's important to recognize that that
benefits microbes are apparent in other
parts of our world particularly in soil
and plants and in industry but in
dealing with medicine I've classified
them in a large way of those that are
therapeutic those that are predatory
those that are dealing with signaling
and there are two examples shown on this
slide which help again begin to organize
our thoughts that in fact a
Bifidobacterium has been used as a
search and find marker for a particular
kind of bladder tumor on the same hand a
particular kind of cancer has been dealt
with in a detection and predatory manner
by essentially detecting a bladder tumor
also and by addressing its demise by
essentially being able to replicate and
in so doing that is the Salmonella
begins to destroy the tumor itself so
beneficial microbes can be a variety of
things with a variety of purposes one of
the most common is lactobacillus the
other one is probably Bifidobacterium
and if one looks at what things they
possess and how they work one can begin
to define some of the features that
would highlight a good beneficial
microbe and a bad beneficial microbes or
one that is not so capable of being
beneficial to the host over a period of
time it is these features that help us
begin to distinguish who in what
microbes might be the best as far as
beneficial bacteria and particularly
beneficial fungi
however I've been in science a long time
and I've been probably half of my life
has been dedicated to the study of
biofilms and one of the thing is it's
now becoming apparent is that a good
beneficial microbe a good probiotic is
one that forms a very healthy biofilm
the photograph on the upper right hand
corner is that of an endotracheal I'll
film within the endotracheal
that areas on the lower right-hand side
describe how we have looked at and
defined a biofilm as in stages and the
reality though is that a biofilm is as
outlined a developmental biology it's an
immobilized enzyme system and it's
steady States but it's a community of
microbes generally mixed that are able
to perform tasks that greater than the
individual because there are components
that help reinforce each others part to
the system before you go to the next one
I do want to emphasize though that as we
talk about the microbiota and we talk
about the micro biota it's very
important to realize that we are as much
colonized with fungi as we are with
bacteria and the reality is we know very
little about that now discuss us a
little bit later but in the original
studies of the human genome and the
bacteria associated with those regions
we sort of left out the fungi and that's
an important feature that down the road
we will need to address as we get a
complete more complete picture of who we
are both from the human in from the
microbial population
well if microbes are so important in
fungi how do they work and what is the
shared option that we now have benefits
to the bugs and benefits to the human
benefits to us and who we are but then
who we choose to share our cellular
mechanisms with what is the benefit of
that and in our original studies as this
is evolved we began to think of
ourselves as the beneficial microbes in
three distinct areas although as I
pointed out earlier we want to make sure
you realize that this is a a region that
it fuses into other regions but the
reason these slides are to the right
oral and gut or gastrointestinal are
clearly the regions that we've have now
the most information about beneficial
microbes in places it in fact we might
be able to use the intelligence of
microbes to help us become better in our
dealing with health and abnormal
consequences obviously as you've all
heard the majority of the microbes that
we have initially studied have been in
the gastrointestinal tract and that is
partly the reason that we begin to begin
to understand how there is a response
and how there is an attitude of microbes
being able to communicate with other
distal parts of the human body and it
still being addressed this is not
something that's clearly been finalized
but it's something that we're getting a
handle on and we're getting clearly an
opinion that it's a quite a complicated
system and the reality of axial
communications between microbes and Homo
Sapien cells has been at least for the
moment divided into four components in
the upper left of this slide we have the
capacity of microbes to direct signal on
the B we have metabolic signals are
coming from the host which help direct
the microbes to enhance or reduce a
particular single signal see specifics
species specific signals come from the
biofilm imagine cooperation
and that that bugs within and the
microbes within the biofilm interact is
a community and alter the axial signal
coming from cells in response to human
cell signals and then the last is D the
accident conditions where there is a
direct pressure or species which elicits
transcriptional responses in other words
when humans and bacteria are together
and sharing benefits this transcription
of DNA to RNA to protein is coordinated
so that there is a shared benefit to
both of the members who are in this
pathway so what are the mechanisms
knowing that there are essentially at
the moment four pathways what about the
mechanisms of action and and how do
beneficial microbes particularly
probiotics of which we know the most at
the moment is representing mechanisms of
action you can see here listed at least
five and one of them is a very obvious
they can inhibit growth of pathogenic
enteric bacteria they can block
attachment particularly in the GI cells
they can down regulate certain toxins
being produced by pathogenic microbes
they can improve the epithelium mucosal
barrier function particularly short
chain fatty-acids in the gut and really
where most of the current research is
going they can alter host immune
response
they can either up regulate or down
regulate in illogic capabilities and
that is where there is at the moment
such a huge focus given that although
the beneficial microbes and potential
use of probiotics are important that is
where there seems to be a clear
direction to get the best of our dual
citizenship and of the dual capacity of
a shared microbial world with our human
cells the last part of this section then
is really how do
these cells having that we now have some
mechanisms we now have an idea how they
actually communicate through the systems
with potentially four routes and one of
the growing recognitions is that at the
end of this communication scheme needs
to be an actual action group of
molecules and it seems to fit very
nicely to what has been described as a
yin-yang hypothesis or good and bad hot
and cold and the bottom line again is
there are those consequences of this
cascade which will be beneficial to the
host as shown in the bottom and the
light blue color and that those that are
absolute deleterious to the host
so in again the simple sense of how
beneficial microbes may be beneficial
and how if the wrong microbes are
present and the shared gene expression
is not beneficial it can be essentially
deleterious we now have what we're going
to call the yin-yang hypothesis which
has been first so well based in cancer
in cancer chemotherapy and now coming
over to the hollow genomic theory and
the concept of dual citizenships well
now we we really have the opportunity of
addressing that part which I find most
engrossing I suppose because then it
helped me think my thoughts into a
hopefully organized format and I'm going
to talk about something that I had
thought about but it's going to be
called the microbial clock and microbial
clock as I mentioned a moment is key in
sort of recognizing that if in fact
there is this dual citizenship good
things and bad things can happen over
time in sort of a cascade of information
so I'm going to talk about the clock I'm
going to talk about certain one
infectious disease and then we're going
to talk about the areas of our research
most recently recognizing again the
beneficial microbes and that is wounds
and most recently aging
it became apparent to me that as we
began to synthesize all of these
separate entities in human disease and
look at them particularly in a manner of
endogenous diseases he could begin to
look at it as a clock and I decided the
clock could go in essentially for areas
defined by colors of green yellow orange
and red and those clocks would help me
begin to place into the development of
Homo sapiens and it's corresponding
micro micro biota diseases that are
associated with age and how these impact
particular timeframes in our growth and
recognizing that there's always been
this disparity of how these might be
linked what started me on my path to
putting this together was dr. Blaser who
said that connecting multiple diseases
through a single framework or underlying
cause was it perhaps more malleable
weight than trying to define each one
separately and I list as you can see
here all of the diseases that are ten of
the diseases which are human but follow
a path and again that was very
interesting because if you take those
diseases and look at this microbial
clock but now begin to emphasize the
disease and the associated changes
within the micro biota and look at again
those six microbes or phyla that
represent a cluster of microbes or
groups of bacteria one can begin to see
that through time there are changes as
one would expect but the reality is now
we begin to have a target that we could
either be associated with a marker the
bio marker are one that to be associated
with a declination or a decrease of the
microbes and from that we could begin to
think about adding bacteria back into
our organ systems given that there is
this potential of now being able to
profile good bugs and bad organisms or
good phyla in bad phyla there's a really
interesting hopefully diagram that will
make you think a minute but taking this
approach of
micro biota and the concept of a healthy
and then a deleterious microbiota or
dysbiosis in the gut we have on the
left-hand side sort of a hamburger and
we have the consequences of the problems
that can occur in eating that and then
the kinds of GI microbes which might be
enhanced on the top sort of those that
are beneficial on the bottom those that
are not we can have then the
consequences of the mechanisms we talked
about and then ultimately the target
tissue information against yin and yang
as the consequence of what we have done
to the microbiota of our
gastrointestinal tract you are not what
you eat you are what your bugs eat is
perhaps the sort of loose ended but sort
of fun way of explaining what we can
look at and one of the major traps and
unfortunately particularly here in West
Virginia is the recognition that obesity
is our number one problem in the age
group of what I have called the orange
and growing through the adolescence and
if one addresses obesity and one
addresses microbiota and the phyla one
can say that weight and diet and
microbes particularly the phyla of firm
acuity is in the back to our deities by
those that are associated with those
that have a obese figure whereas those
that are having less of a city and and
not the problems associated with weight
loss or weight gain have another kind of
a phial enhanced environment and the
reality is that phyla transmitted or
microbes or gut associated microbes can
transmit this situation which begins to
point out that microbes are the players
in these diseases
it's the clinical microbiologist however
I really wanted to to deal with two very
appropriate diseases that I am very
interested in and one is that wounds
chronic wounds wounds that are
associated with the breakdown of tissue
and it began to be apparent to me that
this process was and dealing with our
colleagues both a disruption and a
reconstruction and the disruption could
be handled by doing something different
to disrupt the pathogenic biofilm
but perhaps reconstruct a beneficial
biofilm in these stages that are
represented here it came to me that this
was important because in one of our
studies looking at gauzes and looking at
particularly anti-infective impregnated
into the gods is that if you see in the
upper left-hand side we have actual gods
that are impregnated with a particular
compound when we tease those actually
apart although they were releasing the
compound as shown by the the clear zone
on the right hand side you can see that
in fact there is a growth of the biofilm
material from the inhibitory impregnated
gauzes and that there were biofilms
within the dressings so that in the
middle of the diagram you can kind of
get an idea that the wound bed has of
mitotic a biofilm environment and the
dressing maintains a a biofilm
environment and we clearly thought that
if we could stop this ping pong effect
we could address a better enhanced
healing process which led us to go to
looking at different and alternative
sites and so we basically came up with a
comprehensive wound care should-- in the
destruction part deal with the classic
debridement suctioning maintenance of
the pH and then a disruption with some
form of anti biofilm product but then in
the middle addressing reconstruction
with that particular group of beneficial
microbes or particularly a group of
selected for
biotics and what we began to think about
was couldn't we make a better gauze and
could it enhance the beneficial microbes
which were a part of the original tissue
to begin with and we began to think
about having a smart gauze and if you
look in the lower left-hand corner
you'll see that the smart was for a
symbiotic both pre and probiotics with
mixed species that could produce a
biofilm that we're addressing antibiotic
resistance by not inducing that
resistance and by having a therapeutic
response particularly associated with
antibiotic stewardship we began to look
at microbe particularly lactobacillus
and all I want you to recognize is that
if we use single microbes growing on a
wound bed multiple microbes of two
microbes or three and then use
lactobacillus read three
we got a varied response depending on
how many microbes were in the wound bed
which would be logical we focus then
essentially on what was our next gauze
or smarter number two we looked at
biofilms and we used basically a live
dead stain and if you look at the right
hand side you'll see the consequence of
a lactobacillus red three probiotic in a
wound encased gauze and you can see that
over time we could reduce the not only
the average numbers but the biomass and
whereas green is living in red is dying
the concept of putting on a gauze
addressing a wound bed when the inoculum
being a probiotic as a beneficial
microbe would not only begin to have
some stimulatory capacity but it
certainly was inhibited right -
particularly staph aureus which let us
then to the final concept of this part
and that was I wanted to recognize
another major issue in wound care and
that is that goss's never seemed to fit
the tertiary or 3-dimensional
architecture or the contour of a wound
and it became very apparent that as we
wanted to design a new delivery system
we needed to do so with something that
actually would be impactful at the
tissue interface or where the biofilm is
in its highest concentration at the
basement membrane
when the reality is you can take a
digital camera you can take not only x
and y but you can take z and you can
begin to develop a concept of filling a
gauze with a particular kind of material
that would have the shape of the exact
wound bed architecture we then happen to
align ourselves with people who aren't
very strong in ink based 3d printing we
came up with our smartest which is now a
a level 3 and level 4 in investigation
and we are now able to with digital
imaging and with probiotics inserted
into the reconstituted protein carrying
material carrier and now a microbe in
favorable environment to a wound bed
that is a smart and not antibiotic
inducing a combination of products so
that's one part of where I've been with
looking at beneficial microbes
particularly my interests the other is I
must admit as I'm growing older I'm
looking at what about these newer
diseases or what about these diseases
would have to do with cognition and in
this life in front of you you'll see
that I began to think about the
microbial clock in parallels or in
combinations and you'll see that in the
upper left hand circle it talks about
dementia at an older age and it talks
about in a variety and circle autism in
a younger age and then the lower circle
all together some postulates have said
that we could live to 142 in the future
and I kept thinking about with my
microbial clock what would be the
composition of our microbiota at 142
both bacteria and fungi so again wanted
to think about what I might do in
looking at these things so I went ahead
and began to look at what is it
that is associated with particularly in
this case autism associating with a
disease of learning and I had to back up
because began to think about how do we
address our microbiota and
it come from and one of the very best
articles I ever read said you know what
Mother's delivers twice in a vaginal
delivery mom's delivered not only the
infant but they deliver the first
contact with the human microbiota and
how important is that in the development
later on of learning and cognition and
how does that relate later on to the
lack of cognition in those who are
beginning to have dementia and although
not the topic of this presentation we're
to antibiotics fit in and who and what
is the benefit of a cesarean section if
any versus a vaginal delivery which in
fact delays them the proposition of
microbiota being established and the
dual hypothesis when I began to look at
then areas of theories of Aging without
going into something that I'm just
myself beginning to become enormous ly
engrossed in the idea was that there is
the host and there is the environment
and that the host had as it says on the
lower left hand side either program
death or damage based death that was
interactive with the environment is
shown in number two what you need to
recognize now is that the NIH has said
or postulated since 15 that perhaps
aging is associated with microbes and it
in fact should be called a disease and
when one begins to think about that and
looks at aging one of the reinforcements
of our genetic strength of the host has
been the slow acquisition of
environmental gene pools coming from our
other sources whereas the acquisition of
beneficial microbes being inserted into
the lifestyle of the human at some time
would be a rapid means of providing a
genetic strength and a library which we
haven't thought about and so yet this
idea is to point out that where we've
been is 1 & 2 where we possibly might be
going in either looking at something
like autism or looking at something like
dementia and Alzheimer's disease we
might be looking at the inclusion of
beneficial microbes
along that same line there is this issue
of longevity and the reality is here
that we clearly think that there is when
one kind of separates just the point of
our capability of thought but begins to
look at aging as an overall there is
clearly to look on the lower right hand
side some data which is beginning to
show that there is a shrinkage of our
microbiota there is a potential
acquisition of genes which help some
live longer which is part of that
environment and there is that fraction
of the population which clearly has that
capacity but it's the gut microbiota and
those as means of linking through one of
the four possible pathways associated
with long life which we ascribe at the
moment to unique food that is there some
benefit there - I told you early on that
I was at the dental school at West
Virginia University in addition to being
in the Department of Pathology and it
became apparent as we began to look at
the kinds of oral health that occur and
particularly patients who have very poor
oral hygiene and we looked at the
composition of that oral health and its
impact over time could we begin to
describe a profile or signature of a
microbiota which would enhance either
detection of an unusual scenario or what
we begin to find some things that were
unusual and as shown here the first
three bars our first two bars
essentially to the left are those that
are from normal patients and as we move
from left to right we reach to dementia
and I want to point out to you that if
one looks at the listed phyla as the
upper right hand side or the listed
family members you can begin to describe
a very real difference in that in fact
not only is the gut microbiota
associated with potential changes of
lifestyle but certainly as a marker
those microbes which are associated with
oral health or oral disease are also
potentially a marker and a potential
target for down-filled use of beneficial
microbes so without again going too long
and getting getting bound up in this
scenario I want you to realize that we
now know that in the neurologic sense
and in the guts interface through at
least one or two pathways there are
those that are listed in front of you
for common Alzheimer's disease or in
fact autism disease and you can read
those at your leisure but the reality is
and bi-directional neuro Chamorro
communication system is involved in both
there is an air of developmental deficit
associated perhaps with gut microbes and
that there is an appearance of dysbiosis
both in early age and in the adult age
and the mechanism by which these might
Hantz I'm an act I've shown you on the
lower right hand side which is the yang
Yang hypothesis so this is what is where
we are and it comes back to Martin
Blaser who in essence said that we lose
our microbiota over time and that this
vertical acquisition as we lose items in
a stepwise fashion could be arbitrarily
benefited if we had a potential
horizontal acquisition and the key is if
we talk for more and more time you begin
to see that we look at our clock and we
look at those diseases which are new in
life or old in life there seems to be a
pattern of microbes that are missing and
we might be able to associate some
disease profiling that would allow us
later on to bring into effect beneficial
microbes which could complement what is
might what might be missing as we grow
older in diseases that we have now began
to ascribe is associated with a
combination of both the bacteria and the
human environment this slide is
something that I put together that I
being a clinical microbiology we so
often deal with antibiotics but I want
to point out that as the literature's
beginning to become highlighting these
problems please recognize the
is the microbial clock helps synthesize
new porn and clinical childhood diseases
asthma and autism particularly are
untoward consequences in an acid lessons
there are continuing studies that say
that all these may be associated with an
unbalanced microbiota but the bottom
line is the feature of that imbalance is
associated with overuse of an amide
Coble's so in this last section and
having given you a little bit of hope of
background of what I had done and where
I am I want you to realize that that we
have been trying to explore the
educational component because that the
information is almost bewildering
there's so much out there that both the
the the medical community the
professional community and the public
means to continue being appraised of
we've done what most educators do which
is tried to put it together in a useful
format and I'm going to talk about then
some of the types of things that we've
done but they want you to realize I love
this it's a the picture is a Rubik's
Cube and this is I think in the use of
therapeutic bacteria were in sort of the
Rubik's Cube era where we we have gotten
a lot of information but we surely need
to be getting more information though
excuse me
so there is a plethora I love that word
of published excuse me articles that
address the the concept that there may
be a place for modulatory capacities of
microbes beneficial to diseases whether
they be endogenous or infectious and if
one takes these and begins to assimilate
there is a recognition that in all of
this there is a huge worldwide use of
probiotics now probiotics can be
classified as one type of beneficial
microbes but what I want to show in this
slide is that there are regions of the
world that have much more access to
probiotics like antibiotics and that
these regions have become now centers of
studies which the United States is
beginning to get involved with but it's
it's striking to me that 30% of the
population now uses probiotics
and it's estimated that in 15 the year
2020 there the business of probiotics
from an industrial point will be about
eighty five point seven billion dollars
which is quite remarkable what I want
you to think about though is that as we
talk about the microbiota and we talk
about us I want you to think about the
organ systems and the reality is I want
you to think about the microbiota as an
organ system unstructured but clearly it
has the capacity and functional needs of
Homo sapiens of all the other systems
that we've talked about and as I
mentioned early on we don't want to
trash the microbiota
we want to have stewardship of our what
used to be called normal flora today
we'll call our microbiota and our
microbiota you can think that if you're
talking about organ transplants or we
start with microbiology as a form of
addressing beneficial microbes you can
think about those that are many
transplants when we've been working with
using means of gums lawson Jers milks
and cheeses which have a word in
organism called lactobacillus referee
probe dentist which clearly addresses
and is is good in some studies as anna
microbials and reversing periodontal
disease on the other hand to think about
clustering difficile in the the
incredible problems that is caused in
the US we now know that in the world we
now know that this is not a disease of
microbes clustered in difficile in and
of itself it's a disease of lost phyla
and there are at least three to five
phyla that are incredibly important in
balancing what has been a normal flora
or seed if all of these produce fury
which inhibits c difficile so the
reality is as we unmask our diseases we
begin to find as the population of
microbes decreases the benefit of having
a beneficial or probiotic replacement
either from a family or from a
constituted laboratory defined
constituency we could address both many
transplant and maxi transplant
as a mean of using preventive or
beneficial microbes having said that
when I began to look at the literature
with my students in the dental school
and began to find out how many people
had very little information and did not
know much about probiotics we began to
review the literature about five years
ago and again because of time I want to
point out though what we put together as
addressed on the website here was the
concept that we could look at both a set
up where we could make a decision tree
that would be separated by professional
and public and we could look at as
you'll see in a moment in the review of
310 articles is outlined in the tree we
could look at the conditions described
in those articles we could look at the
probiotics the microbes what were the
abstracts and then also give a value to
how good was the study or write-up or
summary and who was doing this so that
people would have the ability to be able
to actually search to gain more
information on a date and on a website
which would be educational for any group
both professional and those of the
public and we found that there were 11
diseases of which there were significant
studies done in the last 10 years on
beneficial microbes or probiotics the
most the largest studies were done in
oral as you would imagine and more
recently in gut as I already described
to you however in addition to this which
is available on the website in addition
to looking at what microbes were most
most useful and what were the the
studies and how valuable were they in
our estimation most recently our lab and
yours truly has looked at wounds and
aging as you now know and so the bottom
line is I have put together also another
source within our website of looking at
the literature that has described both
in the wound Avenue and in the aging
Avenue two populations what's out there
now and you can see articles that are
listed you can see what kinds of
microbes they've used and who they were
thought that is the strength of the
study
but let me point out to you that in
either looking at the theories or
looking at the published articles on
treatment with probiotics in wound care
the reality is most of these are of an
international nature they are limited in
scope and that is the beginning of now a
era where we would like to see some of
these studies go from industry to
medical studies where we actually have
double-blind studied control groups
which takes money funding and time it is
a beginning but we surely have places to
go in both the wound theory getting new
information and the microbes that might
be beneficial in looking at aging at
exactly the same point of reference here
are the articles here are the conditions
that were addressed and under the study
what kind of them were they where they
would use when the animal studies and
what I would point out to you here is we
look at the theories on Aging and the
published data about probiotics helping
and the absolute research you'll see
under strength are in the middle of
these tables which you can clearly have
access to on the website the bottom line
is there is an enormous amount of room
for better newer and more detailed
studies in how aging and probiotics may
be a benefit to both the bacteria and to
the host but there is much room for
improvement but I am still of the
opinion look at the microbial clock
looking at who we are in the whole of
Geneva theory that we are a dual
citizenship we clearly need to outline
that basic cooperation or symbiosis but
we also need to recognize that other
investigators are looking at other parts
of who and what microbes are also
involved in these diseases which let me
down to the nearing and the conclusion
of my presentation and again coming to
the clock I thought well if if I've
looked at diseases under a and we've
looked at bacteria present and we looked
at bacterias see in the lower-left
bacteria missing and now the increasing
evidence of fungi and where they
fit would we be able to put together a
unique profile or pattern that would be
involved with those four criteria
a B C and D and be able to define a
Philo type for each patient who might
have a underlying disease process that
now we have some means of recognizing
what phyla are present what phyla are
missing and could we look at these four
parts within that which leads me to
where we are going these last two slides
are incredibly important because the
cancer success and the use of
chemotherapy and cancer has led to a
population that recognizes the patient
needs to be characterized before we use
treatment not everybody is the same and
in that we now have a word called
precision or personalized medicine and
is carrying over to the non oncological
cancer environment and so that there are
definitely ways in which we can address
this dual hypothesis which when subsets
for each patient will have parts that
will allow us to really begin to tailor
for every patient a potential beneficial
microbes profile and it's got four parts
and without again the time being now
critical I would invite you to look at
this reference it's positioned here at
the bottom again it recognized and that
that precision diagnosis may be able to
help us prove established a file a
profile of a prevention we may be able
to better B disease diagnosis on the
upper right we may be able to choose our
therapeutics and personalized drug
responses and we may be able to enhance
nutritional benefit of again precision
medicine now going into the era of non
oncology and it would be very much a
part of where I would hope we would take
this whole concept of the whole of
genomic theory which then leads us to
the whole idea of artificial
intelligence and there's a whole nother
era but if you can begin to combine the
massive science that is in
Watson the Madison's the mass of science
it's in Babylon which is a United
Kingdom system and begin to define it
with systems like I'd list in the upper
right-hand corner Gideon which allows
one to make diagnosis from clinical
presentation to begin to match it with
antibiotics and the particular ideology
or the microbiology and then our future
would be could we match that to the
particular again the personalized
profile of what microbes might be able
to be best provided to that patient if
in fact that's the disease management
they would best be part of it so in
conclusion really I hope I've been able
to convey to you
well number one something I tell all of
my students we live in a microbial world
microbial world has gained credence and
credibility because of the whole of
genomic theory the concept is is you
particularly move forward in this is we
don't want to trash our microbiota and
our microbiota we are who we are based
on the recognition that we are a human
genome that has with it an overabundance
and particularly overwhelming microbiota
and micro biota and that the benefits of
sharing both to a benefit to each is
what we need to maintain I love this
unlearning the learned you now know that
beneficial microbes are where we will
need to be in the future of medicine
there are those that are in presence
that will be markers for good health
those that are missing that will be
markers potential intervention with a
probiotic or something of nature similar
to that the concept that biofilms and
microbes that have learned to live as a
community and been successful needs to
be very very recognized and surely as
part of a biofilm we need to recognize
fungi that too can grow in a community
of survival which addresses features
that will allow probiotics and biofilms
to persist longer
I think we're looking at a whole new
concept in wound care management and it
addresses the idea that cells can be an
encourage to grow in concert with
microbes which are a part of their
cellular environment that shared benefit
and then lastly I hope that you'll begin
to think of the generation of microbes
that are part of our dual citizenship
from birth to death
they are who we are we need to change
how we feel about the microbiota we need
to enhance and we need to utilize the
genetic strength of that microbial pool
I've listed some resources here that you
can use that will be a benefit to you
not only do the does the United States
have some probiotic guidelines but the
Canadians have some wonderful probiotic
guidelines and in my websites I
encourage you have you the chance to go
to this website because we particularly
highlighted the concept of the hollow
genomic approach the coevolution and I
hope it'll be something that you will
address as time is on your side there
are finally three three very good text
books which form a lot of what I sent to
you today surely dr. Blaser village has
some beautifully addressed missing
microbes and what it means dr.
Perlmutter has addressed how microbes
can be particularly addressed in
beneficial in the brain and then two of
the previous presidents the American
Society of microbiology began to look at
a broader sense but the concept is as we
age particularly it's got people animals
and the environment and in my slide
remember I had one two and three and
that environment is Co involved when the
micro and micro biota we must learn to
get along and be part of it and don't
trash it so with that I think I I'm more
than honored to have had the opportunity
and talk to you and I hope you'll keep
in touch with us have a great day
so long
thank you dr. Thomas
presentation it's time for QA if you
have a question you'd like to ask please
do so now just click on the green Q&A
button at the lower left of the
presentation window type your question
into the box that appears on your screen
and click on the send button
well answer as many of your questions as
we have time for if we are unable to get
to your question we will follow up with
you via email after the presentation
let's get started our first question is
are there pre-op precautions and/or
safety issues and using probiotics as
therapeutic bacteria Stan in it when
when we spend quite a bit of time
thinking about but the reality is that
Roy biotics and and beneficial microbes
have been found to be universally very
safe except for a select population they
have been found to be safe in
particularly adults and children but
that there are those that have
gastrointestinal alterations cancer
patients with the GI tract focus are
those that perhaps probiotics should not
be administered and are always
considered to be a concern should that
be the only alternative the other issue
about probiotics oh and caution and
safety is that storage issues should
always be a handle that's necessary to
look at when one picks out a particular
probiotic one's going to use them and
then there is though the recognition
that probiotics certainly have less
consequences than the use and overuse of
antibiotics and I sort of draw upon that
to show nobody asked me about the safety
of antibiotics as much as they asked me
about the safety of probiotics they are
without a doubt a feature that is
beneficial thank you thank you
thank you the next question is given
their growing popularity and global
demand what is the future of probiotics
and medicine and dentistry given the
potential interface with FDA and other
regulatory bodies national and
international that's another really good
question and it's a tough one
the guiding principles that are still
being referred to over and over and over
again are those that would put out by
the World Health Organization and in
2002 which basically said that a a
probiotic merely being alive and has
benefits that are of value to the person
or people receiving them and that's
about it it's pretty broad and so most
of the use of probiotics has and been
driven by industry obviously one doesn't
have to go very far to find
advertisements about the benefits of
probiotics but there is a limit to what
industry at this moment has provided and
it clearly needs to be a interface with
medicine and some real clinical studies
which would help us get a better handle
on what population fits what particular
group of probiotics I think this is
where this personalized medicine comes
in where we really now can clearly
understand that at certain times certain
certain medications are very much
altered by the gastrointestinal
probiotic or the gastro intestinal
microbiota and we need to be addressing
a use of probiotics and a defined
patient target population and I
anticipate that the FDA NIH driven and
the globe will begin to look at more
serious restrictions on who and what is
classified as a probiotic one of the
issues that I've had a lot of talk with
my colleagues about is that when you do
that you increase the cost and and right
now obviously that is not a big issue
but should regulatory bodies be involved
that could be an issue
and clearly there are differences within
countries one only has to look at the
difference we notice in Mexico in the
use of antibiotics so the international
theater given that there are more
probiotics and antibiotics used outside
of the US that needs to be addressed as
well so this is a an issue which needs
to be an a part of a target but my
biggest issue is we need to recognize
that we don't want to destroy the
benefit by trying to say that one fit
one type fits all that is not the case
we need to be selective and that's why
we have this new idea of personalized
medicine and it will take some time
before all of the regulatory agencies
begin to come into a flow
thank you the next question is given the
importance of health and beneficial
associated microorganisms what is the
impact on the clinical microbiology
laboratory this primary goal
historically has been to identify
pathogenic microbes this is a really
personal question I have been a clinical
microbiologist since 1969 and been
involved with laboratories who have
dealt with the evolution of newer test
methodology trying to come up with a
concept that would give us better
information faster because unlike our
colleagues in chemistry where they were
being able to turn around results within
a particular time frame of minutes the
classic microbiology laboratory are
using culture defined methods was taking
days and it was something that I heard
over and over again we've now evolved
into use of mass spec the MALDI Toth
approach where we can recover microbes
and then identify them within hours but
we are still left with the concept that
the laboratory that is organized has
been driven by Louis Pasteur one bug one
disease or Robert clock as in a pathogen
and we're going to have to find a way of
probably enhancing or developing a
section in the clinical lab which will
deal with the health benefits and what
is the the whole of genomic makeup of
the microbiota and microbiota of a
particular site or a particular patient
with particular disease we're going to
have to go to non culture techniques
beyond mass spec Withrow broadly
adaptations of PCR methodology but we're
going to have to expand in a way that up
to now has not been a part of diagnostic
and clinical microbiology we've only
looked for the pathogen clearly with the
evolution of the holo genomic theory and
the concept of personalized medicine
then the clinical micro lab is going to
have to set aside at least the section
which would be devoid of the classic
method but would be voted to
addressing the major issues what is
present and what might be absent in the
entirety of the microbiome that is
present in the sample provided that's
going to be a quite an issue because at
the other part of that is how do you
report this we looked at new laboratory
report forms and you think about it a
laboratory report form that is classic
and lists a single or maybe two
pathogens out of a blood culture now
we'll be looking at a stool and could
potentially list what 500 microbes but
if we put them into phyla and address
the issue that I mentioned early on and
begin to look at ourselves as who we are
by the phyla and the families that are
present we can begin to get a cluster
assessment of who we are and what the
patient is it will be a very different
part of what microbiology is but it
surely will have to be done in the
not-too-distant future and and that's
one of the reasons I'm still around I
want to see this happen
thank you we'll wrap up with one last
question and that question is as the
emergence of precision and
individualized medicine encompass
encompasses non oncological diseases
how will artificial intelligence change
the practice of medicine that is a huge
huge question and I gotta tell you that
some of those recent articles that I've
read have said that it that the use of
artificial intelligence with systems
that are evolving are going to be a
healthcare strategy revolution not an
evolution but a revolution on the other
hand I've been hearing about artificial
intelligence for quite awhile I really
got very interested in the concept of
focusing on computer assisted diagnosis
in fungal infections giad and in the
early 2000 era and we were able to
develop a scheme where we could really
be quite proactive in assessing a
particular result and what it meant in a
blood culture if a fungal isolate was
recovered the concept here you must
understand is that there is no perfect
diagnosis and and the literature is full
of comparisons between a physician and a
computer ensuring the new computers are
are improving in our physicians
hopefully are improving the bottom line
is there's no question though that an
enormous amount of money is spent and
there are lives lost with missed
diagnosis will artificial intelligence
in the integration of a variety of
schemes focused again on personalized or
precision medicine be the be the
ultimate answer I think that's yet to be
proven I'd like to think so
I'm very much a positive person but I
think that the proof was in the pudding
if you will it has all the intangibles
to give us tools that will be helpful
but we've got to put into it a better
bit of information you know we use the
word in microbiology junk in junk out so
it's going to take some time in my mind
but the tools are available and I
clearly think that it will begin to have
a structured impact on medicine
particularly the clinical laboratory and
particularly infectious disease
laboratory but I'm cautiously optimistic
I want to wait and see if we can improve
what we've done up to this time we need
to do that but I need to see the tools
develop that will help us do that I
would like to win
again thank dr. Thomas for his
presentation do you have any final
comments I hope people will will become
more involved in the in the changing
world of who we are and we'll become
proactive in finding out the benefits of
our microbes they are our co dual
citizenships and they have passports
that have allowed them to be with us and
I hope they will really continue to
evolve any sense of positivity and don't
trash your microbiota thank you thank
you once again dr. Thomas I would also
like to thank lab roots for making
today's educational webcast possible
before we go I want to let everyone know
that today's webcast will be available
for on-demand viewing through December
14th 2017 you will receive an email from
lab roots letting you know when this
webcast will be available for replay
please share that announcement with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event that's all for now thank you
for joining us we hope to see you again
soon goodbye